- [Mark] All right, Diamond.
- Hi Mark.
- [Mark] Hey Diamond.
- Round two.
- [Mark] We are going to try again.
We're going to go around two.
So let's start from the top.
T, tell me, where'd you grow up?
- [Diamond] I grew up
actually between Joshua tree.
(phone rings) One second,
between Josh, Joshua Valley--
Baby let me call you back
I'm the middle my interview.
(Indistinct phone reply)
Let me call you back up in
the middle of my interview.
- [Phone] Huh?
I'm in the middle of my
interview. Let me call you back.
See there's Mark.
- [Phone] Okay bye. Oh what the hell...
- Stupid.
- All right. Sorry.
- [Mark] Just start over.
- Um I grew up in Joshua
tree, DACA Valley, really.
That's where I did my adolescent years.
My elementary, basically elementary.
We saw Elvira from my
kindergarten graduation.
I was the only black in the whole school.
My family was the only black
in the whole community at the time.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- Uh, shit didn't start
really happening bad
to me till I'd say about seven.
Because before that,
shit, I was too young to
realize either everything
was still Googoo Gaga.
- [Mark] You have mom and dad?
- mom and dad
mom and dad was high school sweethearts.
They have a it's nine of us all together.
It's I'm the oldest outta nine.
It's eight girls and one boy
little dysfunctional mom's alcoholic.
Dad was a crack head, crack addict
but very talented and smart.
My dad was the type of
person that he played
Any instrument.
You know, his, his,
his parents was wealthy
so he was the only child.
So he got every thing hands to him
like he was supposed to.
On the other hand, you know
I guess he just took his,
he didn't use his smarts.
He didn't use what he, you know
he did the opposite with his life.
So it turned out the
way it did or whatever.
But he out of prison every time
my dad came home from jail.
There was a baby being made
before the baby was born.
He was already gone.
You know, my mom was a
hustler in the family.
She took care of us.
She did whatever she had to do
to make sure we had the best
everything. Ends meet. She did whatever.
- [Mark] W what kind of kid
were you in high school?
- I didn't like school.
I was already a prostituting by High,
by time high School came.
- [Mark] What age were
you when you started?
- I started at 13.
- [Mark] 13... And that was with a pimp?
- No.
- [Mark] on your own
- [Diamond] Yeah - [Mark] at 13.
- I was intrigued by the
outside of the dress up
and the, you know, the dress up
and in the money, the fantasy part of it.
I had no idea what was headed
for me in store for me.
- [Mark] Do you recall your first time?
- Yeah I know my first
time. I remember, I let
15 cars pass me by before
I got in the first car
and the first car to pick
me up, he was a doctor.
He delivered babies for a
living and I'll never forget it.
He lived in a gated
community, Hollywood Hills.
And I remember going up the
Hill way up in the mountains.
And when we got here, he
wanted me to shit on him.
And I didn't know what he
meant, he said "defecate."
And I'll mind you, I'm 13.
And I'm like, "what the fuck is defecate?"
I have no other skills.
I have nothing.
I don't know what I'm doing.
But defecate was one word I did not know.
And he looked at me,
He said, "you've never done this before."
And I go, "well, it doesn't
matter I'm here now."
He gave me $1000 and told me to leave.
I took me damn near six hours to walk back
down the Hill to get to
the back to the entrance.
- [Mark] So you didn't fulfill his wish?
- No, but he paid me. Ever since then,
I've been hooked. $1000 at 13?
That was like a million
dollars to me at that time.
Shit, I ain't stopped ho-in' since.
(laughs)
- [Mark] So you've been
doing this for how long now?
- Shit 28 years now I'll be 44 next month.
- How do you think this
lifestyle has changed you?
- Um... shit...
I can't even say if it's changed me or not
because I've been in it so
long its like what I know.
What is the change?
- [Mark] Your street
smarts your intuition.
You must be very keen, no?
- Well, I, I say I have good street-smarts
because I studied it really, because
in the beginning I was out
here thinking I knew it all
but I didn't. I was really scared,
but I never showed fear because
you know, you just kept, (indistinct)
the nature, not to show fear.
You show fear, then
that makes you the belly
in the belly of the beast.
That gives him upper hand.
So if you act like you're not scared
it might help you a little bit.
I don't know. It's hard to
explain this life more because
you know you have to be
a really strong person
to be able to endure this life.
You know, everybody can't do it.
You know, first of all, man, and female...
strong and weak
you know, for you to jump
in a car with somebody
you don't know and have
no don't care, concern
about being hurt or to the
bad happening to you, man
you gotta be really strong minded person.
You gotta fuckin' have
you gotta have something besides yourself
like an outter power,
like a God with you to be
able to do that because it's not easy.
Cause everybody can't do it.
I had a bunch of friends
realized the money
I was making the scene I went to,
I was making everything
and wanted to do it
but they just couldn't do it.
You know, they get in the car
I'll, you might freeze or it gets scary.
You know what to say or how to say it.
You know, I think it's
all about communication.
Most men, men are easy.
That's the good part about this job.
You know, we know what
a man wants, you know
and they only think of
one thing at a time and
all you gotta do is one thing.
That's dress it up.
Once you dress it up and show up
they're going to follow, you know?
And your power is in your hand, really.
Most girls don't know they worth or know
shit they worth period.
They don't know they worth.
They don't know, actually
there's not a dollar
in the world that could actually pay
for what I have to give you.
It's not enough money
the world for, for it
but it's a price on, okay.
You know, I try to always
think big, you know
cause I don't like to get swapped.
I got too many habits,
you know, shopping a lot.
I love to go buy shit.
I love playing dress up.
You know, now I got a drug problem.
That's another habit, you know?
And it's not cheap. (laughs)
- [Mark] is crack your drug?
- [Diamond] Yes it is
and um I smoked weed.
- [Mark] How long you used crack?
- [Diamond] I was 26, my first
child, my first drug, crack.
And I didn't like it at first you know.
It was like a weekend thing with, you know
friends and we did on
the weekends, you know?
And then that was it.
But then I got to realizing, shit
this takes away a lot of my fucking prob--
I smoke this shit I don't think
about all the shit I got going on.
You know, I don't think
about nothing at all.
You know I have a "I don't
give a fuck" attitude.
So that's what kinda like got me
mainly in the beginning.
It's not so much my drug now because it's,
first of all it's not the same.
It's it don't get me to highlight use to.
So I don't, I do more drinking
and more smoking weed than I do nowadays.
You know? Cause cracks is not
good as it used to be, so it's
not worth even buying really.
It's not worth even doing it.
And then the people that
come with it nowadays
it makes it no fun.
So I don't even really bother
with it too much no more.
I get my drink on. (laughs)
- [Mark] Have you had bad
experiences working the street?
- Oh my god. Bad
experiences? (long exhale)
Near death a lot of
times. You know I guess
my work my, my, my work experience
was before the streets, you know, at 7
I was 7 years old when I
first got molested, right.
And uh...
that was more horrible to me than
a trick picking me up and
I guess they call it rape.
I don't call it rape.
I call it comes with the job.
You know, I get in the car--
I feel like rape is like
when he snatched you up
take you off and do
some without your will.
When you actually volunteer to
get in the car for some money
and it go bad and that's
just fuckin' part of the job.
That's how I feel.
You know, it just comes
with the territories for me
you know I'm a call rape?
I don't, I don't call none of that.
It impossible for a ho'
to call it getting raped.
I don't understand. You
volunteered yourself
for this shit so that's
what it is. You know?
- [Mark] you've been arrested before?
- Have I been arrested? Man...
One of, my second name
used to be jail. (laughs)
That's why I'm so preserved.
- [Mark] How many times roughly?
- My first time I did 12 years.
- [Mark] oh really?
- Yeah. And I just, did not
just didn't discuss any of that.
All together, I gave the
prisons all my twenties
and half of my thirties. That's
why I'm so well preserved.
I look good for 44 though
I got my makeup on.
- [Mark] Those long
prison terms are for what?
- Numerous things, because
I didn't come out here
using drugs. I came out here, you know,
fast money, you know, fast life.
- [Mark] But prostitution doesn't
get you that kind of time.
- Oh, hell no. But that was, you know,
prostitution what got me involved
with things I had to get
involved with. You know,
that's what made me been
put out there. You know,
you meet people that you don't, you don't
imagine you're meeting, you
know, prostituting, you know
let me say pushy sales. I mean,
fuck Donald Trump goin' come
by for something one day
you understand what I'm saying? So,
you meet people, all
kinds of walks of life.
And I'm always been an
open door policy, you know?
Cause I feel like I'm the
greatest thing, you know
out here. So, you know, I
give everybody the opportunity
to be in my presence.
Cause I love one thing. I'm not an ad--
I'm not a hindrance sitting
there but I'm an asset
far as this my hustle.
Even if you don't like people like me
Cause you know, I got some money.
you know, I might
introduce you to somebody
that you couldn't get introduced
to prior to meetin' me.
- [Mark] What's your
favorite personality trait
about yourself?
- I love all of me really. I can't say...
it's not a lot about me I don't like.
Just my bad feet right now cause
coronavirus living my feet.
- [Mark] Confidence is
a good quality to have.
- Well, I've been, I've
been cute all my life.
I was born cute.
So, you know, I can't, you know
they would call me a lot of things.
But they can't call me ugly.
Cause that's how I wasn't born ugly.
Sometimes I can act ugly
but you have to bring it out in me.
It just don't automatically show.
I have very good people skills
and I'm a very good manipulator.
- [Mark] Are you sometimes
tricking guys out of money?
You're trying to figure
out how much money they got
and trying to get it.
- That's my jobs, to
trick you out your money.
My job is not to do it.
- [Mark] Yeah, sometimes
people think it's as simple
as you having sex for money.
Usually trying to get
the money out of the guy.
- I, I, I very rarely have sex.
I have what you called ghost pussy.
I promise you dreams.
I sell you promises and you buy them
because as long as I looked
like, I looked the part,
you're going to buy it all.
You know, it's not hard to
dress up and to put a face
on it and to be somebody
else. I called myself
It's like Eric ain, Sandra
Luci, all my children.
That's a cold bitch.
But she, she promised she would all the
mother fuckin', the land, all, everything.
It don't get you shit but a hard time.
That's it.
- [Mark] Have you been in love before?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Have you been in love?
- Oh shit.
I've been in lust.
I guess ive been in love twice
and I know it was in love
because it, it, it felt different.
You know?
Any time a man is around you and...
wants better for you and to want
you didn't do good things in your life
It's not allow you to
keep going down the road
that you were in when he met you.
Anytime somebody comes in
life to help you improve
is love.
People that come to your life to help you
to help you tarnish
yourself or to help you
d, disintegrate, that's not love.
I don't know.
I think you have to love
yourself a little bit
till you find love and
you don't, you don't,
you don't come in the
world, loving yourself.
You come in the world
with the worldly shit.
With worldly things.
You have to learn that.
It has to be within.
- [Mark] living this lifestyle has got to
make it hard for romantic relationships.
- This lifestyle pre-- forbids you
to have a romantic relationship
because even if you do like
someone, that's why I liked you,
It's always back in they mind, you a ho.
It's always like, well, you gotta pay me.
So it's our immediate relationship
because every time time I want you--
Every time he touched me, I
want you to give me some money.
I don't care if you are boyfriend
especially if you a
boyfriend, if you a boyfriend
I really want some money. (laughs)
- [Mark] What advice would
you give to a young girl
who's considering doing this?
- You know...
Damn.
- I wouldn't, I wouldn't
want to see my kids doing it.
but if it was a girls out there
already doing it, involved
I try to show them which,
what to do, what not
what not to do to keep them so to survive.
But my advice is,
try something else.
Don't do it.
It's dangerous.
This lifestyle is.
And the more years go by, it gets worse.
You know, it's nothing
easy about this shit
you gotta really know your shit.
You gotta really know what you're doing
to survive out here in this life.
If not, you'll be fucked up, tore up
fast...
Fast.
There's predators out there.
I mean real life
predators people out there
that just come out to harm,
to hurt with bad intentions.
I mean, I got a lot of
homegirls that's dead.
A lot of girls, I started with the game,
they're not even here now.
They're literally dead
or in prison for life
making d- decisions and bad choices.
- [Mark] Where do you see
your life going from here?
- [Diamond] Who knows?
I wish I can see the future,
but I can't all I see is 10 toes down.
All right. I need to be-- I'm done.
- [Mark] All right you're on.
Thank, Thank you so much
for talking with me.